[Musica]
dove andiamo
allora andiamo sotto e qui sotto nel
ricordo allora adesso stefano ci fa
vedere le sue abilità da killer in
questo gioco c'è gente che arriva c'è
gente attenzione ma aiuta vi sono qua
viene a prendere magari attendere via
che la gente mi ammazzi e la gente sta
in fondo lei fondra in fondo difatti
mara stefano stefano va a fare il killer
non è tutto il cielo a fare killer
drogato ma lei non abbiamo le armi non
abbiamo le armi stai parlare
quest'estate aspettano che voglio
firmare questa cosa io prendo le armi
insomma a pugni a pugni i due facciano
picchiami ha fatto il dito medio togliti
goal quota ora che ha investito ma
l'isola caricando il fiorista effetto ma
dossier schifo giocato ad ora fa ma
anche su youtube bene di tipo piega le
chiavi del quad io
dammi le chiavi voglio guidare 1 punto
non voglio fare la [ __ ] che si fa
scorrazzare che ci ha sparato ed il tuo
marito o una macchina che ha le chiavi
dentro dove la emi aveva javier io non
vorrei essere pessimista ma la zona
sicura un po distante da cuore salite
che guido io sono bravo io mai salite
che guidò
questo la testa di un cavallo è un
nemico salita in macchina o 2 litro
destra dritto a destra ma perché qui da
fare perché credo che qualche problema
sta guardando la patente che si fa
vedere preso la patente la stagione gli
oli schivo gli alberi siete voi che
siete miscredenti maledetti visto l'ha
visto dove è stato bravissimo
eccolo 9 è bravissimo e stato bellissimo
non posso neanche uccidermi una grana
pace dai fatti catturare quello che non
sai cinesi giusta si vede che saltava
allora la prossima non guido io guido io
guida stefano
ma allora scusa noi stiamo questa
divinità sul tetto ai a chi stava
sparando tutto fortissimo poi c'è ed i
tuoi in mutande pensate che presenta
sparano per chi è meglio che spari a una
cappa ho ucciso quello che speravamo
no mi hanno ucciso chi è bastardo con le
cose
mad vedi che io sparo alla gente e la
gente lo vedi quella emotiva e morto in
mutande a cavour di nazione ma perché
quello parla contro gli sta svegliando
perché parlo di su tavole uccide stati
orlando quando fai vita allora che
[Musica]
manderà il fiume che quale direzione sul
fiume alla gola a terra in un campo rom
che coincidono nel campo non rubarmi
compiuta una collina ruspa qua la
macchia nostra si era macchiato quattro
ammonizioni la pistola e manca la
pistola ma come pratica questo sopra ci
vuole cacciare di casa ma cosa vuol dire
lo stabile anche urlando prima questo mi
faccio dire tu mamma stava urlando no
aspettami tu col cuore ma secondo te c
entra il quad e nella nella casa è un
cold paranormale potrà entrare la centra
una carica la carica arrivo bravissimo
facevo una certa kabul a quando l'ho
visto prima io ciao
non quindi non mi fido più di te io non
le metto nel mezzo di una macchina per 4
persone
andiamo sull'albero vai vai se chiamo
stefano vaj si farà a 130 in autostrada
hai scritto capito cosa è successo
cappotto e chiuso qui chiuso massimo
cedente celebrato maria l'ho colpito
local machine bush andanti fronti aiuto
ci sta inseguendo la macchina sta
eseguendo non state scoperti e copriteli
addio a como veramente bene a me stava
dietro c'e gente se niente cedente
ma perché non è scaramazza re il suo
gioco di merda non ho preso neanche 11
tis21 macchina
ecco siamo tutti caduti qua alla fine
quindi perfetto no spiega di 10 e csc
pieghe di questo che questo insiste se
no io sono io arrivo e di bardi che la
macchina dietro veloce guardi parti
bagni guardi parti anche che mi sono
fatta prendere stefano vaj prende
stefano stefano stefano perego ea destra
stefano a destra e destra info stanno
sparando in quattro
resiste morto è morto stefano ogni anno
che capisco di eco la massa del tipo che
ha ucciso stefano
reeve olivo e non siamo il testo in
testa lui perché i pugni
mario è nono ricaricare
cioè nulla quaderno precisa pompa poi
c'è gente ci si sente giù ci sente giù
nei nostri nomi appena esci occhio direi
sì occhio c'è un detto appena esci
occhio ed umiliante io non riesca la
mazzata operano lasciata 24 però adesso
il record per lui è in piedi sul sul
palo così è bellissimo dai ragazzi dopo
questo elicottero dai guardo no ai la
cintura lev wrestling ma che figo
io sto arrivando a naruto è mio bastardo
punizione dai adesso porca di quello
[Musica]
vero non è vero atto d'aniello visto io
a yao macchinosi raccogliamo loro
rispondono quasi spalma questo mario ti
odio perché mi hai fatto quasi porto di
arrivo ma mo spinte l'hanno visto
io non voglio che cercava di entrare
dalla finestra
chi è questo ma c'è uno che è uscito di
qua l'ho visto quando ci ho pensato che
era un nemico ucciso
l'ho visto ma pensavo fosse tipo stefano
che poi ci ho pensato perché non mi sa
ce n'è un altro nella casa ce n'è un
altro occhi ho visto l'ho visto la
mirando autonomo rito non morir la roma
non ha visto che non ha un cazzo non è
limitata e un cazzo e invece ai campioni
in questo gioco due caste farne uno
zaino bello ma volevo io non me l'ha
fatto prendere mette la maschera quella
bene così sono arrivano sento sento
sento che occhio ma in via però la via
scalas casa molto
occhio perché c'è quello parlavo cioè
quello che mi tiene a girare si è
fermato mi sa io adesso hanno tratto in
granata sono così di cesa aspettate qua
dietro non sparo vabbè dai 16 di vita
dai aspetta che forse muore perché non è
stato toccato
bastava 32 sono fortissimi basta